[موسيقى]
لم تعد زياره المسجد الحرام تقتصر على
اداء العمره او الصلاه بل توسعت لتكون
تجربه اكثر ثراء للمعتمرين والزوار هذه
ثلاثه معارض تقافيه تستقبلهم بتقنيه
الواقع الافتراضي والذكاء الاصطناعي طوال
ايام شهر رمضان
المعرض ولله الحمد يشهد اقبالا كبيرا ويضم
مجموعه من المقتنيات التاريخيه والتراثيه
مثل الحوامل التي كانت تحمل كسوه الكعبه
المشرفه
والاواني التي كانت تستخدم في سقايه ما
زمزم في المسجد الحرام ويشهد المعرض في
المتوسط 500 زائر في الساعه ولله الحمد
تروي المعارض المقامه في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه حكايا والتاريخ بئر زمزم وكسوه
الكعبه فضلا عن المراحل التاريخيه التي مر
بها الحرم المكي من خلال المقتنيات
المعروضه التي يعود تاريخها الى اكثر من
100 عام جدا ممتازه جدا استفدت فيه كتير
جدا ما كنتش اعرف بعمق البركه عن كام
والمياه وهي موجوده فين وانت عرفتها من
هنا من المعرض عن طريق المكتبه الرقميه ما
شاء الله
انه كيف ما شاء الله
حضراتكم وتقنياتكم الجيده
من ناحيه كسوه الكعبه واتقانها ويظهرها
بالمظهر اللاقمي دينيا
على العموم معرض ما شاء الله اكثر من
اربعين الف معتمر ومصلن قاموا بزياره
المعارض الثلاثه حتى اليوم حاملين معهم
قصصا وذكريات ومعرفه عن تفاصيل وتاريخ
المسجد الحرام من الحرم المكي سلطان
السلمي العربيه